- So Rudy Giuliani is complaining
that the DOJ covertly got access
to his iCloud without notifying him.
And if it can happen to him,
it can happen to anyone.
Well yes,
if the DOJ had probable cause,
then they can serve a warrant
on the service provider
with an order that says that
they can't disclose the fact
that they got access to that information,
or alternatively,
this might not have been a search warrant.
There's something called
a National Security Letter
that's an administrative subpoena
that doesn't give you access
to the content of something,
but it does give you access
to metadata like file names
or subject lines for emails.
And yes,
it's true that it's rare for
the crime-fraud exception overcome
the attorney-client privilege
but that might be what's happening here.
So who knows,
maybe we'll see Rudy Giuliani in court.